hello there reject nation look who's
back on the channel
it's me ken alvarado cat alvarado um i'm
so happy to have you here cat
she is the first female guest other than
my girlfriend of course
to come here because she is extremely
extremely strict with the kova you know
what why do i even preface it with that
who even cares anymore
it's me she's out there licking everyone
all the time
people looking at her just let her be
here all right it's great i'm covered in
slobber and smoked particles
and i was like screw it come on in fans
miss you because halloween is upon us
and people still watch our videos from
the past that are the scary videos we're
gonna watch from slap damn
creepiest things caught on live tv let's
do it but before we do that
kat you have a podcast coming back don't
you
i do if you like creepy stuff i'll
listen to my podcast
villains of history it's coming back
it's on all the podcast places it's
about
bad people from history and all the
horrible stuff they did
yeah it's really fun i was on and up i
was on two episodes yeah and we make it
funny
it's not just sad yeah it depends
you know what's sad my love life beyond
that that's just one of the top ones
i talked with kat uh several text
exchanges
on september 3rd and you know what
oh my god this is more of a conversation
you should have off camera
i wanted to make you look bad on camera
which in turn makes me look bad we're
both equal now
that's equality in 2020. i'm so sorry
i'm the word you even messaged me on
instagram off of one of my birthday
presents like
did you lose more weight barbie was like
it's kind of odd that we've talked a lot
you didn't even wish
it was funny i gave you a problem i was
invited
thanks for the i really appreciate that
i was inviting you on the channel so i
was like
this will be funny if i just bring it up
on the first video
oh my god i'm a bad friend that's okay
i'll just make sure not to wish you
you happy birthday in like a week or
something whatever your birthday
how you doing i'm calling and this is
slap tam today we're looking at the
creepiest things that have ever been
caught on live tv
but as always before we dive in remember
to hit that subscribe button for more
awesome creepy content
just like this get ready cat
i'm ready it's as creepy as his teeth
were i don't know if i could handle it
oh that's
[Laughter]
as the host discusses a recent football
match a groundsman who appears to be
wheeling equipment off the ground
suddenly disappears what
whoa what makes the footage even more
mysterious is the fact that a short
while later
a second man can also be seen
disappearing from the ground
what whoa it's like the when the footy
the
experts were initially stumped however
some suggested that the disappearing
groundsman might have just been an
illusion created by some sort of video
edit
yeah despite this many thoughts did
indeed show
something paranormal while some viewers
were convinced that the camera had
captured ghosts
it's difficult to know for sure without
further information
what what do you think does this clip
really show proof of ghosts lurking
inside this football stadium
did anyone report people going missing
at the football stadium because i don't
have my answer
oh my gosh i guess it was his like
favorite job of his whole life
reported on an 11 year old boy from
spanish town jamaica
spanish have been haunted by a ghost his
family claimed that they prayed for him
and even tried taking him to church
but said that the ghost would have
followed and ended up causing havoc
inside
it's a creepy picture clip begins as the
boy is being interviewed by the reporter
while sitting on a chair
suddenly he appears to be grabbed by
some sort of unseen
force from behind
a woman presumably his mother quickly
catches him
standing by a wall and walks over to
stand next to it
just as before something appears to grab
at the boy this time pulling violently
on his leg
what the hell that is creepy
wow actually a friend of his who passed
away four years prior
oh man it appeared to him one day and
he's been caught
oh my
this footage certainly qualifies as one
of the creepiest things caught on live
tv
legit creepy yeah that's pretty creepy
that one creeped me out
oh my god yeah i'd love to hear about it
whoa it's like it's like he's being
yanked that's
crazy oh my god i'm usually a major
skeptic and that was like
legit video was uploaded to yorkshire
conspirator ufo's youtube channel in may
2019
what do homo sapiens do
near the beginning of the video there's
a sudden flash in the sky
this is shortly followed by an orange
colored orb that slowly descends from
above
it hovers for a few seconds before
suddenly disappearing
the players don't seem to notice the
strange light as they continue their
pre-match warm-ups
while several skeptics have noted that
the descending line could simply belong
to a drone
this theory doesn't explain how the
object could suddenly
vanish the light's turned off
[Laughter]
well done cat you're welcome
in 2016 this mysterious clip first
surfaced
where does it keep disappearing on live
tv what the hell's happening
camera's still
the woman behind her mysteriously
disappears
what i didn't even see it what are you
talking about play it again when the
clip was first uploaded to youtube it
immediately went viral racking up
millions of views in the first few days
whoa whoa how'd that happen
i'm labeling it as evidence of time
travel what if it's a little farfetched
as a jump that was a leap for sure a
glitch in the matrix
however several skeptics have also noted
that the incident could simply be an
optical illusion
created as both women walk out of the
shot together oh yeah
oh no oh no that's not
or could there be a more rational
explanation for the world well yeah she
looks like she's turning and walking
that way
yeah i could see it being that i think
it's that
no stop ruining this okay
another another uh a lot of sports
related
today they get lonely man mysterious
dark figure can be seen running through
the stands
what the [ __ ] is that in pace and
appears to run straight through
okay that is pretty crazy
that was like this is live television
this footage is long baffled experts who
are at a loss to explain who or what the
dark shape could be
a former soccer
many viewers are convinced that the
figure must be a ghost
with some even suggesting that it might
be a shadow person
oh well shadow person changes everything
there's something very unusual it could
just be a reflection
has the camera really captured a ghost
moving at great speed through the crowds
of onlookers
or is it possible that this clip is
simply the result of some very clever
video editing
i thought that was live tv huh
this creepy reporter disappears shape
shifter
is supposedly taken from a reporter
the uploader claims that it could
actually show proof that reptilian
shapeshifters are living among us just
as the reporter is finishing his story
he blinks
revealing what appears to be a second
set of eyes
ew during the video the uploader
mentions that as the reporter had just
finished his interview
he might have thought that the camera
had already been turned off and for a
brief moment lost his disguise
but played all the way through the race
is slowly being infiltrated
just pause it people is certainly a
controversial one
it certainly does have its supporters
the theory mainly credited to former bbc
television sports broadcaster
i think you just caught him at a weird
moment these are actually descendants of
reptilian beings
pretty sure i've looked like a reptilian
being while sneezing like
reptilian breeding programs that have
been taking place
on earth for at least 200 000 years
sweet huh well my ex is a snake so
he has supporters in nearly 50 countries
and often lectures in front of large
crowds
in fact a 2013 poll of americans
conducted by public policy polling
indicated that four percent of all
registered voters
actually believed in david ike's ideas
while this clip certainly doesn't i
don't think very unsettling could it
really show proof of an alien lizard
infiltrator
or is it more likely that the reporters
double eyes were caused by some sort of
glitch in the footage
yes i think it's the latter this is
another piece of evidence that supports
david ike's theory
that the earth is indeed being overrun
by lizard overlords because these are
very
whatever the case may be it certainly
does make for a very creepy video
one shape-shifter world dominating the
overlords
sure it's a glitch guys before we get to
that all right number one
number one alleged demonic possession
caught live on tv in thailand
okay remember to hit that subscribe
button and turn on channel notifications
already done with all
in july 2016 the model began to exhibit
some very strange behavior during a live
interview on a thai talk show
tipper one chapel puang told the host of
the show that a spirit had attached
itself to her
during a recent vacation to the city of
rayong
in the clip she explains that the ghost
known as a pop in thai culture
has an insatiable hunger and at one
point screams
out bring me pig's blood after
explaining her story
chapel pong's demeanor suddenly changes
as she appears to become possessed by
the spirit are sure she's not just
hanging then begins talking through air
she starts to act
very strangely
after several attempts to convince the
spirit to leave the girl the host tries
to place a necklace of buddha around her
neck
the act makes the woman recall in fear
as she begins to shriek
uncontrollably
manages to get the necklace on her and
it immediately seems to silence the
demonic voice
when the clip first boy immediately went
viral across
thailand racking up millions of views in
just the first few days
opinions were divided about its
authenticity however
with some viewers suggesting that the
woman appeared to be acting
yeah that's what cat was doing when she
walked through this door
i do it all the time twenty twenty's
done number one
[Laughter]
who's willing to marry this
thank you thank you have you ever wanted
to hook up with a girl who's acting like
he's demonically possessed i can do that
for you
probably i mean that girl right there
was a model apparently model
and someone who went to acting school
and it's paid off and
wonders she got to go viral the video is
creepiest things caught on live tv in
terms of creepy
i would say yeah most of them even the
ones that i'm like i don't buy it are
still
creepy at most of i can give it that now
the question becomes
what is real and what is not real so
creepy yeah get that out of the way
they all are indeed real or not this is
where cat comes in
mythbusters style she goes in and goes
light turned off glitch that's all
morons and a video that's all she does
but you got creeped out by a couple of
things i wasn't expecting i like
bringing you on for these because you're
very skeptical you're a skeptical human
and i'm i'm like a little catholic boy
on the inside who's like
oh my god everything's real the
apocalypse is coming
i mean it is but but you know
how do you explain this live tv one with
the person this
the first one they showed us the live tv
one this is this one is tough this is
one of the ones that got me you know but
i would say
sometimes you see stuff and it is
okay i did a kegel all right let's do
this
nothing to do with anything i just do
that when i clear my throat i understand
okay people just walking around a
stadium and disappearing
what is this definitely a ghost let's
move on
all right knock that one out
my best guess would be some kind of a
some kind of this one has to be i have
to think about it like
it could some kind of a camera glitch is
never seen you so stumped
i'm i'm legitimately stumped i feel like
i don't know enough about cameras
i want to say it's a lighting thing
because i've seen like the orbs the orbs
you can pretty m myth-bust pretty easily
because there's usually some kind of a
lighting
elsewhere in the frame and it like
bounces off the camera
sure whatever and makes the orb i
imagine something similar is happening
with the people in the stadium i mean i
feel like it would have been a big deal
if people were disappearing from the
stadium though that's well they're not
people disappearing they're ghosts
they're ghostworks oh they're ghosts who
are appearing
oh say i believe that
[Laughter]
with this kid though he could have some
kind of medical condition to which i
don't know any of the proper terminology
i'm not gonna even talk about what it
didn't look like possibly
it didn't look like a medical condition
to me at most it might be that he's like
really good at physical stuff like the
moonwalk
you know how michael jackson was gonna
unlock this is like
a different thing that's similar like
that where they're doing something
physical with their body that's pretty
impressive
causes the optical illusion that they're
being pulled away
but that seems far-fetched to me this
one looked pretty real this looks real
especially when the
little boy is getting yanked i know the
first one with the chair really got you
wait wait wait play that in reverse
again from where she's pulling him
right okay this way what if it's
reversed video what are you talking
about that'd be harder like just throw
the kid into that position where you
just relax
you can't just reverse him into that not
if you rehearse it if you rehearse it
you can do a lot of things like have you
watched ballet
swing dancing salsa like there's a lot
of stuff you could do if you rehearse it
i'm just saying so i say real
shut this [ __ ] down damn all right
i already covered this i i think i think
you're right the ufo watching the
football game hey i don't know why ufo
would be watching a football game but
i mean it's fun i mean yeah
we need an assessment of humans let's go
to a kid's football game
it's like women's soccer too yo is it
yeah those are women oh god no
the aliens shouldn't be going to women's
soccer games you know what you know what
i mean
they're comparing men and women and
they're going like wow the women are
better at soccer than the men
i don't think the ufo was thinking that
why don't they get i don't think i don't
think the alien was thinking
that cat they should really get paid
equal to or greater than them
pretty sure he was like they are the
inferior race
[Laughter]
and cancel you're cancelled greg i'm
taking your channel off
i know i'm that's what i'm sending cat
up for today
it's the only way to get justice she's
gonna send me a pile of comic books
this big time this one in the airport
the only reason i believe it's optical
illusion
is because it looks like she's talking
to her right yeah she's talking to her
and this would be a big deal if like
some [ __ ] like my friend disappeared
in the middle of me talking okay i'm
looking at her face
okay i'm gonna go frame by frame here
right this is super slow for you guys to
make my editing life so much more fun
look okay you see her jacket so she is
turning
she's turning in the direction as if she
is walking with the woman
if anything she walked out at the same
time as her
and the camera just caught it ah come on
man
that's like too perfect you can't even
see her through like this girl's
ponytail
if she's standing closer than you think
then this woman is gonna be taking up a
pretty big amount of space on the camera
it just depends on how far apart they're
actually standing
and if this has some kind of a fisheye
lens that could also affect
i i think you're wrong she's definitely
time traveled
i love how they just jumped from oh man
this girl might have disappeared because
she's a warlock
and then all of a sudden they're like
time travel evidence time travel
there's not even time in this so the
soccer one another soccer one
see men's soccer clearly this shadow
figure or ghost must be related to the
alien he was scoping out men's soccer
and he got
very excited and was starting to run
with the team
he's like i'm just so energized but all
this masculine oh this masculine energy
because the females under deliver this
one also got me i was pretty
stumped the best i can say is probably
some kind of camera glitch which i know
is so
unsatisfying it's unsatisfying to me too
much like my love life
okay why can't you just stick to the
topic
my explanation for this is very
unsatisfying much i think it's because
this shadow represents your love life
right
mike's like bread
okay see if it was a camera glitch i
would have we would have seen
something like mirroring it somewhere
else in the frame
for it to have been like some kind of a
light thing
so i just don't i don't i just don't buy
it i think it's a ghost it's a shadow
what else would it be come on what what
wait oh
wait wait oh my god okay look there's
another one
oh [ __ ] there's two
you're right they didn't even point that
one out
dude sorry don't sue for
putting my hand on your shoulder like a
brush
moving at the same time which is bizarre
and that makes me wonder what okay
there it is over there yeah i know i see
it
everyone turn the camera off what's up
there's something here oh good catch
we've contributed to the video now
this reporter is definitely a
shape-shifter part of the reptilian race
everybody's a reptile oh my god this is
proof let's call it
let's call it a day everything else is a
skeptical thing
but this this one's true definitely a
reptile race that's gotta
just be a glitch yeah no reptile would
be stupid enough to just like [ __ ]
shape-shift out what was he like getting
tired was he couldn't
could he not maintain his human form
long enough look okay
look all right see either reptiles are
smart enough to rule the world or
they're stupid enough to show that they
exist
like you can't be both if they rule the
world they're not gonna do this they're
gonna
exactly thank you if you're on
especially for a reporter he knows
they're recording and that's live tv
he wouldn't just shapeshift out no they
know better
they're smarter than this they're
reptiles unless he's the one dumb
reptile in the bunch you're like we're
just gonna put him on camera
yeah reporters are dumb right like
they're dumb
everybody else is like in their prime
ministers it's like justin trudeau
the more you break it down the more have
the more i believe you cat yeah i'm not
gonna believe this elrond hubbard dude
all right yeah that's mostly a bunch of
anti-semitic stuff i've heard
not to make it serious anyway moving on
keep politics out of this political
discussion that's happening in this
video
this one acting 100 it's kind of yeah
there's there's nothing
it's creepy i i can imagine you're
watching a live tv segment
and you're like what's this chick doing
i think what was unclear to me
was that she come on to do some other
interview and then
this started happening or did she come
on because she's like i'm possessed by a
demon i don't know this
but i will tell you that there are a lot
of movies where people play
characters who are being i don't know
devoured by zombies
or people are playing zombies and if an
actor can
pretend to be a zombie then an actor can
present
pretend to be possessed so what would be
her goal here though
they hired her because they want to make
a viral video well wouldn't her career
be done after this or is like her whole
career you know
one of those like she writes a book or
she becomes this inspirational role
model of like how i overcame my demon
possession
people are willing to do stuff if you
pay them enough so they're probably like
look we really want our show to go viral
more have this publicity stunt
we will pay you a million dollars to
come and do this and she's like i could
use a million dollars and she did it
in thailand sure
whatever i don't know i don't know
anything about thailand's currencies i
don't know where that tone came from i
mean
i mean whatever dollar amount is is the
amount that would make someone be like
i'm doing it that's probably what they
offered but she has such a good modeling
career to be invited onto a live tv
station
all those models with hummingbird
tattoos right here man but she's really
committed you got to give it to her
though it takes balls
great action it takes balls to go on
live tv and do this for sure has balls
but it also seems fake yes seems really
fake especially this guy who's just like
all right let me handle this demon
possession this is a
[Music]
let's not bring an expert in for this he
happens to have the amulet by the way he
happens to have the buddha amulet that
is gonna
take care of this whole problem never
mind that in the exorcist they have to
call an
expert this tv show host has
the special amulet convenient
too convenient let you have that moment
all right guys well what did you think
is riddled around man only one video
shot with you
here 30 minutes into filming my god out
of the norm for me guys
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell subscribe to slap
pam's channel
and also check out cat alvarado's
podcast villains of history villains of
history
and uh you're doing a fundraiser are we
not i am it's called
laugh across america it is a fundraiser
for the biden campaign
it's a show it's a 12-hour zoom comedy
show
you don't have to watch the whole thing
just watch whatever you want you get a
passcode to watch the entire zoom comedy
show
and all you have to do is donate to the
biden campaign at
the link below that he'll include
in the description box it'll be
in the description it's not just
all right no no no
and patron of the day shout out
deonte w tongue punch fart box now if
there's
anything i've ever experienced while
being live
on a live stream and that is definitely
creepy
it's whenever we shout out one of our
top patrons right now
deontay w tongue punch fart box
nothing like saying hey big thanks to
tongue punch always feels good yup
that's the kind of supporters we have
and if anyone's a proper
representative of the kind of support we
have
it's someone with a title like you it is
certainly creepy
to know where you like to put your
tongue what you like to punch to create
a fart
and have a little box encompassed around
your face
deontay you rock our asses deontay
with your tongue punch and fart boxing
magic
now normally this is where i go but in
all seriousness and then i get sincere
i don't think you want that nah
we're done thanks deonte later dion
you're the best
love you keep farting in people's boxes
and punching them in the butthole